You want me to talk about
when I come home at night
and my sons ask me
what I did today?
I actually say, well, I had
a meeting to talk about,
what are the core attributes
of a Disney princess?
One of the most
important things for us,
is show young women who are
empowered, is vital for us
to tell stories that
better reflect the world
that we're doing business in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's no way that you
can achieve great gains
without taking great chances.
I'm going to cover a number
of subjects-- leadership
attributes, how to
manage creativity,
how to develop a strategy.
The role of humor
in the workplace
is just an extraordinary
distraction.
And there really is no place
for humor at the Walt Disney
Company.
I'm going to tell some
interesting stories about some
of the biggest acquisitions the
Walt Disney Company has made.
There's a picture on
my desk of my shaking
hands with Steve Jobs.
That moment enabled me to say to
Steve, I got this crazy idea--
we want to buy Pixar.
When you create a brand,
ask yourself the question.
When I put that brand
name on the product,
what does it convey?
If I say to you, Disney,
you know exactly what it is.
It is a feeling inside you.
You immediately have a
visceral feeling about it.
My greatest hope for the next
generation of business leaders
is that they bring to
the job great integrity.
And they achieve things that
ultimately create a better
world and a future that looks
brighter than the present.
I'm Bob Iger, and this
is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]